the approach of this video is to provide
the minimum information needed to start
experimenting with recording and live
streaming with OBS and then go a little
bit further from there this is a screen
capture of OBS 30.0 being recorded with
OBS 29.1 from a second monitor download
this free open source software OBS from
OBS pro.com there are going to be three
sections to this video the first is the
recording live streaming equation which
is going to introduce the fundamental
equation the second section is going to
be step by- step getting ready to go
live in OBS recording or live streaming
and then the third section is going to
be live streaming lessons and checklists
so first the recording live streaming
equation video equals Audio Plus visual
visual in OBS is what you see is what
you get what is inside of the black
rectangle will be included in the
recording or in the live stream what is
not in the Black Box will not be
included that's the visual Rule and the
audio rule is capture and balance the
correct audio sources which we'll look
at in the second section so let's go to
the second section getting ready to go
live in OBS so a few things about the
interface of OBS first it's very
flexible and customizable and there's
different themes we'll look in the end
at the settings about adjusting themes
but your version of OBS may or may not
have the same theme and may or may not
have the same starting layout as mine
here however different sections are able
to be moved and dragged
around so it's very flexible and you can
find out what works for you one of the
most important things are the scenes and
the sources so the scenes are like the
different zones or moods that you want
to be in and I put scenes and sources in
the same window because once I'm in a
given scene I'm only interested in
looking at the sources and the sources
are broadly audio and visual
contributions to the video so the
approach that we're going to take in
this step by step is start with a fully
working setup and then do a few actions
that are important and see how to
reconstruct those actions also from a
blank slate but here in the context of a
working setup and on the controls side
we'll look at the settings last as well
and the studio mode penultimate
streaming and recording do what you
think recording saves it locally only
streaming sends it remotely only and you
can hit both buttons at the same time so
first let's balance the audio in the
audio mixer section there are two audios
here condenser microphone and desktop
audio so I'm speaking locally on a
physical condenser microphone phone so
it is spiking and then here I'm going to
bring in another audio Source that's
going to play locally so this is
connected to desktop audio which means
all outputs from desktop audio right
click add and then audio capture
depending on the options audio input or
output capture audio input capture is
more like a microphone audio output
capture is more like a local source so
let's balance the audio between the
condenser and the desk top the general
principle is to going to be first to
have them balanced but second to have
them near their full dynamic
range rightclick Advanced Audio
properties and I'm just going to resize
this and move this window
slightly if it's quieter than peaking
that could be fine but it might be too
quiet and you might miss out dynamic
range and if it's too loud then it's
going to be too loud so first I'm going
to set the condenser microphone phone
and I'm changing the percentage volume
just speaking in a normal way until it's
peing red 4 149% in this setting and
then just pulling back a little bit 383
per. now desktop audio but it still
peaked a little bit because I moved
position so I'm just going to pull it
back
more uh this composite no this gold
observation node with a goal
prior so what this says is um do
GV based optimization around this note
this just because it was playing out
loud at my computer it also spiked the
condenser which it wouldn't do if you
were wearing headphones which is a good
reason to wear headphones but here the
desktop audio was peaking and I moved it
up to 125% to be balanced so now we're
this could be a video that you're
capturing and doing a reaction video
with or this could be a video chat and
audio playing through your video chat so
if you're in the video chat room talking
and needing to record you need both the
condenser microphone audio and the
desktop audio which is what you hear
through your headphones if you're using
another computer to live stream from or
you're just live streaming the meeting
and you don't need to speak through a
microphone you would only need desktop
audio so we're good on audio now let's
go
into cropping and window sharing so here
Source add
window capture or screen capture here
it'll be a window
capture they move
around you can resize contrl Z
undoes and you can do most of the
operations that you expect like contrl C
and control V for copy and
paste one common thing to mention here
is right click
and properties is where you can crop so
here's a cropping view let's just say I
wanted to show this video but I wanted
to remove the top bar of the browser or
the YouTube sign then crop top just
using the scroll wheel or arrow keys or
typing in a
number you can crop it to
only the section that you
want so let's say just this
section do modif the
object I'm deleting the one that I
copied and now we can stretch it out
more you could also do different kinds
of Transformations and filters and
things like that rotating and so on so
again to the big equation Audio Plus
visual we're capturing both the
microphone locally and the audio coming
through the headphones both sides of the
conversation we're featuring the main
content that we want to feature whether
it's a video that you're playing locally
or a YouTube video or a video conference
and then there's an image here and then
there's the text so properties
rightclick properties of the image you
could just change which image it's
pointing to you can also do in sources
rightclick add image you can play all
kinds of different things through those
sources and then modifying plain text
rightclick properties just typing out
the
text right click
adding and then different texts find out
what works best on your computer and
your setting but that is all the
information needed to recapitulate
basically how this was live streamed
just a few days ago in terms of the
image text audio visuals and the capture
here was of
Zoom a few other notes recording or
streaming in studio mode so here we are
back in OBS clicking Studio mode splits
out into two
screens the one on the right is called
program and this is the one that's going
live whether to a recording or and or a
live stream on the left is preview so
this is kind of like the adjacent
possible or the offstage so then we
could say well we know we're going to go
to a break and I want the break to look
like this so on the right the program is
still showing the people talking and the
audio is still being Lo
but then I know that we're going to
switch to text and image only and then
when you hit transition that goes live
and then you can say okay when we come
back from break I want it to look like
this and then transition and you can
modify the way that transition looks and
how it fades out so Studio mode is
pretty simple and it's a good way to set
up a scene you can also switch to a
different scene behind the scenes so
here switching from this one now we're
in a different
scene and last let's look through the
general
settings here is some of the theme
information for how it looks and what
language it's
in stream this is if you want to do live
streaming where you can manually copy
and paste in your stream key which
anyone who has that can stream to your
Channel or you can do different kinds of
logins so there's different ways to
stream the output
is the bit rate of the video and the
audio different encoder
settings audio is which audio sources
are which and what
the audio mixer shows in terms of this
spiking meter videos where you set the
resolution and frame rate hotkeys
there's a lot of options for advanced
OBS use to do different things with key
combinations accessibility has different
color options and advanced has some
further options including stream delay
and automatically reconnect which are
good to have enabled and those are
pretty much all the settings of OBS
there's also a lot of plugins and a lot
of ways to level up and use OBS in
really interesting ways so that's all
there is to say about composing the
audio and the visual so that you can hit
start
recording last section of the
video live streaming is incremental
transmitted remote recording briefly I
will review the roles-based approach to
live streams that we have found
effective as a draft contribution into
this space so just review some slides
that we have built up over the years at
the Active inference
Institute some tips on live streams they
are
totally just presented as what we have
done other contexts are going to be
different some of these are just general
comments though on live streamings that
you might find useful respecting the
context and audience being clear and
consensual about how words and images
are being captured and recorded and
used joining on time or understanding
when and how people are going to be
joining if it's a live recording for
people in any role on the live stream
having a comfortable setup for them and
in terms of buying a webcam or
microphone if you can there are
sometimes good microphones available new
or renewed that are quite good and will
get you very far almost up into the
professional level of recording the
microphone that I'm speaking with now a
condenser microphone that was probably
30 to4 Us in
2020 webcam of course similar there's a
lot of different ways to make your
visual appearance how you want to be
seen from having a higher resolution
webcam or lighting or different
things there's different video options
in terms of your computer for reasons of
digital and cognitive bandwidth it's
good to close any and all extra program
so there's no messaging alerts or
distractions things popping up on the
screen these are for people who are
going to be talking or even just
participating in the live stream and
using appropriate language and
behavior different things that people
may want to ask before a live stream and
different protocols that participants
might want to be familiar with in terms
of how they can participate for people
who are going to share their screen it's
really important to cover up all the
extra information close all other
windows or use a separate computer so
that there's no possibility of sharing
the wrong window and make sure that you
figured that out before the live stream
if possible the broadcaster the person
who's using OBS has some different
checks that they could make in terms of
all the scenes and the settings the the
audio included and balanced visuals the
stream key and the video resolutions
which can't be changed live the internet
bit rate the video bit rate which can be
adjusted during the
stream this computer especially it's
important to close even messaging
applications they can disrupt some
Network
continuity and to be
ready facilitator a little bit outside
the scope of this video but whatever
facilitation Style is
relevant and live streams are organized
events so ensuring that the organizer is
also part of all these conversations and
the planning and all of that so I hope
in this video with the fundamental
equation of recording or live streaming
video equals Audio Plus visual visual
what you see is what you get audio
capture and balance the correct audio
you have the broader framework to head
into this very general tool OBS compose
the audio and the visuals that you
expect and
prefer test you can do a private live
stream you can also do recordings it's
good to do recording and make sure that
the audio and the visuals are how you
expect them to be and then you can go
live and go from there and last piece I
hope that was useful looking forward to
people's contributions and improvements
to the space bye